you know the view is just so absolutely
ridiculous Barbara Walters is rolling
over in her grave the whole thing is
such a ridiculous farce but for some
reason a certain set of people pay
attention to it and I would like to wake
up those people and it's also on at the
exact time as us right now which I take
a certain pleasure in
um but Sunny Hosten who I think is
genuinely the most unlikable person on
television and as I said Joy Reed is on
television so that's a hell of a
freaking statement for me to make she
got into it with Alyssa Farah now Alyssa
Farah is the quote-unquote conservative
at the table so you've got you know four
lefties basically and then like a pet
conservative and they got into a fight
that I just think is so like emblematic
of everything wrong with television and
media and politics and the whole damn
thing take a look I think he wants power
I think he wants so much power that in
2017 he closed public beaches to all of
New Jersey except for his family and his
son so he could have his son's birthday
party on the beach I think he thinks how
does he get power by entering the race
but what scares me Alyssa is that you
are incapable of Defending a man that
you worked for that you know why did you
ask me a question I did ask you a
question
and you said that you needed to hear
more from him and I don't need to hear
more from Pence for several reasons
because when I live you just accuse me
of something so why don't you let me
actually answer you're not going to vote
for a pumpkin now I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna finish what I'm gonna say
um the thing about pants here is that
when I lived in Indiana and I went to
Notre Dame he had a terrible approval
rating because of the way he treated the
AIDS crisis
full a lot of people died because of him
a lot of people died because of how he
handled the covid crisis
yesterday
he also was a parrot for Trump
Sonny likes to make it personal for me
so we'll just he's swelling are you
going to give me a chance
spearheading troop uh trumps
agenda of downplaying the virus this is
not what the show is about this is
Barbara Walters everybody
and
[Applause]
okay yeah actually I was hit like this
like I can feel like a tumor growing in
mind I hate you Dave yeah I apologize to
you guys I apologize to everyone
watching I apologize to my team here why
would I do this to any of us Liz it's
interesting because look Alyssa is
obviously well compensated and again
she's just getting exactly what they pay
her for but someone like you could sit
in that seat right like you you would
you would knock it out of the park which
is why they'd never hire you for that my
friend Lisa Booth who is absolutely
awesome and fearless uh they had at one
point maybe said that she could be there
but she was not vaxed so they wouldn't
even let her in studio to to audition uh
I guess I have a couple questions for
you would you even consider the gig and
uh
what do you make or just what happened
there or do you have any sympathy for
someone like Alyssa I suppose who's
let's say maybe a little bit on more art
side of things but is what it is
no I have no sympathy for Alyssa she's a
very silly person she is an intellectual
lightweight and she needs to act like a
grown woman if someone is attacking you
then you need to know how to defend
yourself if someone is steamrolling you
for the purposes of humiliating you so
that they they portray to the world that
your political views are somehow
illegitimate then you need to interrupt
and you need to do it in a way that
actually interrupts not not fluster and
flap around like a like an agitated bird
like she does so no I don't have a lot
of Sympathy For That being said Sunny
Huston is like a very mean person she's
a very nasty person
um so I I if I were in Alyssa's seat
that would not be happening but like I
said Alyssa it needs to act like a grown
woman and this wouldn't happen to her
foreign